with these
poetry hi I'm kit young hi I'm Danielle
Galligan Namaste I'm a meter Suman
hey I'm Callahan skogman I'm Freddie
Carter hello I'm Jack Wolf and we are
the cast of Shadow and Bone reading your
first tweets with BuzzFeed
[Music]
thinking about the fact that we're
living at the same time as kit young
Freddy Carter Amita Suman Danielle
Galligan and Callahan skogman how sexy
of us I think that all the time did you
do this because
you did this it's very sweet really
amazing very sexy very sexy I'm watching
Shadow and Bone and I have literally no
idea what's going on but
go on oh I'm putting there's just very
hot oh yeah she is very hard I'm sorry
that it was going on hot girls don't
want flowers hot girls want cars bracket
and murder murder people in Shadow and
Bone season two
hours or murdered
Nina zenik making fun of cars Brecker is
something I find to be very sexy
100 degrees it's just rude how Jack Wolf
walks around being cute and I'm not
there to witness it
was thirsty it's like it's like
he's like why don't we have a cup of tea
together yeah
kakimi prisoner and drag me across
Frozen wastelands whenever he wants
devil emoji
make it sound like beat poetry yeah yeah
kit young should be arrested for being
so sexy he sent many people to
their Death Beds early today I sincerely
hope not uh I hope you're okay but uh
thank you for your candor all the crows
are bangers Kaz Brecker intense
energy
sexy Jasper Fahey layered while and
Vanek adorable Matthias helvard down
hard
what does that mean I think we can all
guess but I like it I like it I wouldn't
say layered is this no it's not I have
developed unhealthy habits this is like
my sixth time watching Shadow and Bone
and at this point no one can stop me
from simping in Edge oh she's so like
hot that's two letters
is so hot Beyond reasonable doubt he
says something like a legal matter
I like the the heart with like sparkles
Emoji to make it just like yeah yeah how
do you pronounce sexy I personally
pronounce it as Nina xenic
that's Saucy town if your favorite Crow
is wylin or Jesper you're hot as I
don't make the rules
I'm not wrong they're not wrong I wrote
that too as well oh God it's all caps
that act accordingly please I would die
for Danielle Galligan and Calhan skogman
I don't think you all understand the
grip they have on me I'll gladly walk
over hot coals carrying the weight of
the world if it meant they'd be happy
wow wow well put your money where your
mouth is
Jasper Fahey looking sexy and reminding
everyone the power of bisexuals yes sir
yes sir yes sir
no no let's hug it out well let's take a
walk together waiting for the day Freddy
Carter reads my he's the mayor of sexy
Town tweet
listen I know that Danielle Galligan and
Callahan's kogman are just two people
playing Nina and Matthias but I
want what they have and I'm tired of
pretending like I don't I love that you
ever cry over how a door
call hand skogman is that hot and sexy
and he has beautiful handwriting ah I
hate him so much I would let him break
me in half
he is Kurt International no American
cursive handwriting Champion I'll have
you all know is that right finalists
that might have been the only contestant
okay but when Jesper shot the volcra
while holding Milo he looked so hot
there's like a paternal thing in there
your child protecting my child yeah yeah
that's right
Justin
foreign
van Eck could step on me and I'd thank
them that's a lot that's a lot of people
I have bench all episodes of Sharon bone
yesterday and I'm not okay I bow down to
both Dinesh kafar and Anita Suman yeah
she's Beauty she's badassery she's Grace
she's the queen and she could step on me
I think Anita Suman an inertia file
would be very happy with that
Freddy Carter could run me over with a
car break with the bones in my body and
spit on me and I would crawl my broken
ass back to him Danielle galligan's
accent is so hot what else has to be
said call an ambulance I just remembered
that wylan and Jasper are canonly the
hottest couple in ketterdam big talk but
you're not wrong
um
calhan's garden and his Matthias
Hellgate look please daddy rip me
to shreds I can't wait to stand a
Thor Ragnarok like Matthias salvor
that's so hot I need a minute there's
something about your radiator
the reading of them is so intense only
hot people are madly and hopelessly in
love with kit young but is kit young
only in love with hot people this isn't
about me my life has 99 problems and 108
of them will be fixed when I get hugged
by a meter Suman Freddy Carter kit young
Callahan skogman Danielle Galligan and
Jack Wolf
do a good group
behind every hot person there is a
severe anxious attachment and an
obsession with a meat assuming
um for noodle I lied I don't actually
like sex but it floats back on I'm going
to explain kazbear's delicate love for
anesgafar and what it means for my
expectations of real life men
I like that it's a little boy panic I
have every time I hear Danielle
galligan's laughter this face it's so
cute in her last story why can't I have
a cute laugh like that oh
thank you
[Music]
then oh wow
good morning we will get to see wylan
Vanek on screen soon I don't need
caffeine anymore I just wake up and
think about this and I'm literally
standing on my bed I could rip out trees
right now I'm so energized
on my TV can you imagine I can't imagine
I'm very excited
I didn't know that Callahan Sky we could
get any harder but this man has
exceptional music tastes OMG take my
hand in marriage and listen to Amber Ron
with me please that sounds quite nice
Inez and Jasper look so hot bark
bark bark bark woof woof bark bark woof
one more time
that's what that is
all thank you we've had a great time and
make sure to watch Shadow and bone on
Netflix thank you
[Music]
show me